ce lémurien qui est un lémur mongos de
Madagascar fait partie d'un ensemble
d'une collection de lémurien qui a été
ramené par le premier conservateur du
Muséum Auguste LZ qui a dirigé le musée
de 18 163 à 1893 on lui doit une
collection remarquable à plus d'un titre
d'une part parce que c'est une
collection qui est presque complète au
niveau du nombre des espèces
représentées mais c'est aussi
remarquable parce que c'est l'
celui-même qui a naturalisé les
lémuriens et ces lémuriens on voit que
c'est quelqu'un qui les a vu parce qu'il
n'y a pas d'erreur de posture ils sont
tous parfaitement naturalisés et et
lance a été formé au Muséum de Paris en
tant que préparateur c'est-à-dire c'est
ce qu'on disait au 19e siècle pour le
taxidermis mais LAN on lui doit
notamment plusieurs campagnes à
Madagascar à au séchel et aux îles sa
Saint-Paul et Amsterdam et grâce à ça il
a enrichi de manière phénoménal nos
collections des îles de l'océandien
occidentale